Transcriber: Lubna M.A. Shurrab
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
مرحبا بدأت خطوات حياتي الأولى في بيئة
المخيم ، للمخيم نكهة مختلفة .
بس في وجع خاص .
كنت طفلة مشاكسة جدا ، بحب
الحياة، بحب التأمل .
وكنت ذكية بدروسي ومتفوقة بمدرستي،
ودائما مفعمة بالنشاط والحيوية.
وكنت أيضا أشارك في الحفلات الغنائية
يا خي قول لأمي ولا تقول لأبويا.
وإثنينهم عدوا
ناويين
علي وا ها ها ،
يا وعدي.
وبعدها
وبعدها تزوجت،
تزوجت بعمر السبعة عشر ونصف.
عشت صراع كتير كبير .
خفت خفت على أحلامي إنها تندثر وتروح .
كنت بأعتقد أن الزواج من رجل شرقي هو
مقبرة مقبرة لأحلام النساء .
كان الزواج حائل،
حائل بيني وبين دراسة الطب
أو العلوم الطبية لأنه ليس هناك جامعة
بالجنوب تدرس طب الذي كنت
أعتبره حلم الحياة .
التحقت بجامعة الخليل تخصص فقه وقانون .
كان تخصص جديد.
بس من اللحظة الأولى قررت، قررت أني
أتفوق على كل الظروف الاستثنائية .
وأن إيماني بتحقيق حلمي وأهدافي
ما يتزعزع ولا للحظة واحدة .
وبالفعل بالفصل الأول صدر اسمي
قائمة المتفوقين.
لكن نهاية الفصل الأول عرفت إني حامل .
بدت ملامح الحمل تظهر.
وبدا التعب، وزاد الإرهاق، خصوصاً
بعد اعتقال زوجي السياسي.
عشت ظروف اقتصادية ونفسية
صعبة جدا، صرت أفكر كيف ادبر حالي،
أريد أن أتجاوز أزمتي المالية والاقتصادية.
فقط في البداية، بعت جزء من مصاغي الذهبي .
وفتحت مشروع، وهالمشروع لتنسيق
الورود والأزهار .
كنت كثير شغوفة بعالم الديكور
والتنسيق والألوان .
وبالفعل حققت نجاح كتير ممتاز في مشروعي،
وتصدر اسمي في قائمة المتفوقين
للمرة الثانية
كملت، بالفصل الصيفي كملت وسجلت
مع أن تقديرات الأطباء تقول
أن ولادتي ستكون فترة
الامتحانات النهائية ، قررت أن يوجه كل
طاقتي حتى أقدم الامتحانات بالموعد المحدد،
مهما كانت الظروف.
وفي ليلة امتحاني الأخير مادة القانون
الدستوري، ضبطت المنبه الساعة
الثانية عشر ليلا.
الليلة كانت كتير مختلفة، صحيت على
دقات ألم ما عمري حسيت فيه.
اعتقدت يمكن أن يكون هذا ألم المخاض
ما خبرت حدا.
أصريت لوالدتي أنه يمكن أنا معي طلق،
لكن أنا أريد أقدم الامتحان صباحا .
استمريت بالدراسة وإكمال المادة.
مرت الساعات القليلة كأنها ألف عام.
اختلطت فيها كل المشاعر .
الإصرار .
والخوف .
والحب.
ميلاد ابني الأول وامتحاني الأخير.
صباحا توجهت للجامعة.
قدمت الامتحان، قبل موعده بقليل
دخل كل الطلاب للقاعة.
كان كل خوفي بالامتحان أن تبدأ
الولادة قبل ما أنهي
الإجابة على جميع الأسئلة .
بس كملت، مع أني كنت في حالة
مخاض أخير بالنفس الأخير .
بعدها توجهت مباشرة للمستشفى
بعد أقل من نصف ساعة، كان ابني الأول
شعبان الجميل بين يدي
عندما رجعت إلى الجامعة، أخبرني الدكتور
أنني حصلت على العلامة الكاملة بالامتحان.
وبالسنة الدراسية الثالثة كان موعد ميلاد
ابني الثاني عبد الرحمن المقدسي.
جاء لهذا العالم يوم الخميس 23.4.2015
يوم السبت كان عندي امتحان أوراق
مالية وتجارية
اطلعت من المستشفى على مسؤوليتي الخاصة
روحت درست للامتحان، يوم السبت
ذهبت قدمت الامتحان، لما رآني الدكتور
حكى لي بإمكانك أن تقدمي الامتحان غير
مكتمل، شو جابك،
قلت له بأقدر أقدم الامتحان، وحصلت على
علامةواحد وتسعين بالمساق.
تخرجت ثلاث سنين ونص، 147
ساعة، تقدير ممتاز مع مرتبة الشرف.
شعرت بالانتصار .
بس طموحي لسة زاد، وهذه المرة،
كانت المحطة الثانية
جامعة بيرزيت،
تخصص الفقه والقانون
سجلت الماجستير .
كان هناك كثير تحديات .
جامعة بعيدة، والدتي رفضت،
ما بدها اياني أبعد عن أولادي،
وعندي بنوتة صغيرة اسمها سارة يادوب
ثلاثة شهور.
بس ظليت مصرة، وفي الفصل الثاني
اشتغلت بمعهد مواطن،
مشروع تدريب المكلفين بإنفاذ القانون،
حسيت حالي كثير أقوى
وحسيت عندي طاقة أكبر،
وحصلت أيضا على
الدبلوم المهني في العلاقات الدبلوماسية
وتسوية المنازعات الدولية
من كلية هاربرد للتدريب.
واليوم أنا عضو في المجلس الاستشاري لإعداد
المحكمين العرب السي سي إيه
رقم عضويتي200
وبعمل أيضا في وحدة
الريادة والإبداع .
هالنجاحات الكبيرة التي حققتها
هي بسبب الطاقة الموجودة جوانا.
يمكن ظروفي رسمت لي خط معين
وحددت حياتي في مسار معين .
كنت أتمنى أن أكون طالبة جامعية عادية
تنتظر تخلص المحاضرة وتطلع الكافتيريا
وتتشمس وتتسوق مع صديقاتها، بس أنا كنت
أروح أركض
حتى أهتم بأولادي وبشغلي.
بتخيل يمكن كانت المسؤولية أخف
لو لم أكن بأدرس
وبشتغل وكمان بربي أولاد، بس ما كنت
رح أحظى بنظرة الفخر اللي اليوم
بشوفها بعيون أولادي
لما يحكوا للناس من هي أمهم .
فربنا وضع فينا طاقة عظيمة.
وهالطاقة الي جوانا لازم نوجهها
وين إحنا بدنا نكون، لازم نحب أنفسنا.
ونؤمن أن احنا أشخاص لنا قيمة خاصة .
ونجعل هذا الإيمان أكبر من أي خوف،
وكل عقبة بحياتنا بنواجهها نحولها إلى
درجة نطلع فيها لفوق.
ولقبي المرأة الحديدية
هو كان لقب من عمي، حماي،
كنت أتمنى أن اليوم يكون موجود بين الجمهور
ويقف وأول حد يصفق لي، لكن للأسف،
هو اليوم عند ربنا وكثير كثير حأكمل على هذه
الكلمة اللي حكالي اياها
وبحكيلو اليوم أرقد بسلام، منحني
الكثير من الحب، ومنحني كثير من السلام
ومنحني كثير من الطاقة.
فاليوم بحكي ألف رحمة ونور لروحك،
والألم الممتع هو الألم الذي يقودنا
نحو التفوق والنجاح.
شكرا .